la chimère dans la mythologie grecque
c'est une créature millions mi-chèvre
misère pan mi-dragon c'est aussi le nom
qu'on donne à un animal qui a plusieurs
profils génétiques en lui et chez les
humains il y a quelques cas célèbres il
y a par exemple le cas de Lydia ferre
shined et tout commence quand elle
demande une pension alimentaire au père
de ses enfants on leur fait passer des
tests génétiques à tous les deux pour
prouver qu'ils sont bien les parents
résultat c'est bien le père donc il va
devoir payer une pension alimentaire
mais pas à Lydia parce que les tests
montrent que elles par contre c'est pas
la mer les juges veulent rien savoir ils
pensent qu'elle est en train d'essayer
d'escroquer son ex et il lui retire la
garde de ses enfants et comme elle est
enceinte du troisième ils envoient une
espèce d'huissier surveiller
l'accouchement et faire faire des tests
sur le bébé dès qu'il est sorti et
devinez quoi le bébé n'est pas d'elle
non plus heureusement il y a un avocat
qui a déjà entendu parler d'une histoire
de chimérique un petit peu dans le genre
et qui conseille à l'idéal de faire
d'autres prélèvements à d'autres
endroits de son corps ça finit par
concorder avec l'ADN de ses enfants et
tout rentre dans l'ordre si ça c'est pas
une histoire incroyable je sais pas ce
que